ahoy ladies i didn't see you there would
you guys like to set sail on this ocean
of flavor with me i'll be your captain
i'm steve harrington now the 2020 is in
our rear view we can focus on the great
tv coming out
this year so today we're going to break
down the most anticipated shows of 2021
right now on the ketchup and by the way
you can check out the full list of the
most anticipated shows of 2021
on rottentomatoes.com last week we saw
the debut of one division the first
official mcu original property that fans
have seen since 2019 and consider our
expectations raised kevin feige that's
why we're so pumped for the next phase
of the marvel cinematic universe even if
it's on the smaller screen
and next on the docket is the falcon and
the winter soldier
set to debut march 19th the new disney
plus series covers the exploits of the
new captain america aka sam wilson or
falcon played by anthony mackie and his
partner the winter soldier
alias bucky barnes played by sebastian
stan the official series description
claims that falcon and the winter
soldier are teaming up to bring down the
flag smashers which were a splinter cell
of villains created by marvel to be
specifically anti-patriotic
rather than hydra's brand of nazi
fascism the trailer released during
disney's investor day last year gave us
some tantalizing clues
we spotted daniel brroll's baddie helmet
zemo last seen in captain america civil
war
baron zemo as he's known in the comics
could easily be a flag smasher
especially since the events of civil war
put him at odds with hydra
and the avengers either way we are
excited to see bucky and sam partner up
and we are all so stoked because there's
a rumor going around that chris evans
might make a cameo as the original cap
somewhere eventually what's going on in
that cyborg brain of yours
you don't want to know next up is the
return of everyone's favorite sociopath
murderer
dexter while the original showtime
series ended in 2013 with what many
consider one of the weakest finales in
television history
this new limited series seeks to wipe
that from viewers minds by reintroducing
us to michael c hall's character
a former miami homicide blood splatter
specialist who moonlighted as a serial
killer
who only kills other serial killers
original showrunner clyde phillips is
back and hall himself told the daily
beast
let's be real people found the way the
show left pretty unsatisfying
and there was always a hope that a story
would emerge that would be worth telling
i include myself in the group of people
that wondered what the hell happened to
that guy so i'm excited to step back
into it
last seen as a lumberjack up in oregon
because apparently that is still a real
occupation
dexter will go head to head in his new
adventure against the latest big batter
the always spooky
clancy brown and while we don't have an
exact air date just yet
expect to see dexter sometime this fall
he will not believe what i found
let's be honest when it comes to takawa
tt the term too much of a good thing
does not apply though he's busy
directing marvel's thor love and thunder
acting in dc's the suicide squad and
assisting as an evp on fx is what we do
in the shadows
the new zealand director is at work on
another half hour comedy for the network
reservation dogs teaming up with native
american writer and director sterling
harjo the series focuses on four
oklahoman teenagers as they spend their
days fighting crimes when they're not
committing them the premise seems like a
natural fit for the kiwi watiti whose
indie hit
hunt for the wilder people balanced
comedy against more serious themes of
how we treat indigenous cultures
and whose academy award-winning jojo
rabbit focused on a young boy in world
war
ii germany turning away from nazism
starring deferra wunati
devry jacobs paulina alexis and lane
factor expect to see reservation dogs
later this year alongside watiti's new
movie a sports comedy called next goal
wins i don't think i can do this
last of course you can and while a slate
of new and rebooted shows is very
exciting we are
so stoked for the return of stranger
things for season four
for anyone who needs a refresher season
three of the hit netflix show ended with
hawkins's chief of police jim hopper
apparently sacrificing himself under the
star court mall to save the town from
being destroyed by both the russians and
the mind player millie bobby brown's 11
ends up leaving town with hopper's love
interest and badass mother
of the year joyce byers without her
abilities or her boyfriend mike wheeler
played by finn wolfhard
but hopper is still alive being held
somewhere in russia according to
promotional material for the new season
which was actually halted in march due
to covet
but with the tagline we're not in
hawkins anymore expect to see the show
expand beyond its indiana roots
and include more global threats to
humanity in the upcoming season which
has definitely been confirmed
for 2021. if anyone asks where i am i've
left the country
and finally we have the highly
anticipated return of donald glover's
masterpiece
atlanta so when we last saw glover's urn
all the way back in 2018's robin season
it looked like he might be out for the
count
he was told by darius that he was about
to be fired by his cousin paperboy
after finding out that his daughter with
van was gifted and needed special
schooling
what's more he had accidentally brought
a gun into an airport on an
international flight
but irv finally learns how to play the
game when he hot potatoes the gun and
becomes a little wiser and harder for it
critics and fans rejoice when season 2
brought in 16
emmy nominations we've been waiting a
long time to see where the story would
go
after being delayed off its original
premiere day in january 2021 due to
kovid production
is resuming soon and although the
premiere day isn't set we can't wait to
see the next stop on earn paperboy and
darius's journey out of atlanta
this year is this real alright friends
well that about wraps it up are you
excited for any of these shows on our
list and what do you have on your
schedule that you're super stoked to
watch this year please let us know in
the comments section
and of course definitely check out the
rotten tomatoes is wrong a podcast from
rotten tomatoes
because fresh rotten is just the
beginning of the conversation and new
episodes drop
every thursday and if you don't want to
miss out on any future episodes of this
show be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell and as
always
muchas gracias for watching the ketchup
and happy binging
bye
[Music]
you